okay you want to go ahead and take
over okay so it seems like the troops
already little tired after
lunch so and
no no hard proofs in this one
I think a lot of really interesting and
important and fascinating Concepts but
I'm not going I again so I
will mention a a few proofs but then
from each proof I will try to single out
one or
two small things that I think may be
interesting and wor word for you okay so
again we we're talking about uh this uh
subject of high dimensional
combinatorics and and
really for permutations we have a
perhaps a more round story to
tell here here we have more things to
tell but perhaps it's a bit more
groundwork that we have to prepare so we
have to start with with a definition so
let me say perhaps one thing one
caveat there's going to be an elephant
in the room the elephant's name is
topology but don't worry it's a very
friendly animal it will not hurt you and
uh so I will only here and there you
don't need to know any topology to
follow this absolutely not but for those
of you who have some background in that
here and there where where we H come to
a close encounter with the animal I'll
I'll just point out and say that okay
this is anthropologists would consider
it but there's really absolutely no no
need to okay
so this
is this is the basic definition perhaps
the name
sounds somewhat impressive but it's it's
really a very simple and very natural
combinatorial object and I'll explain
the the connection with with
combinatorics with geometry I will will
be speaking completely combinator so a
simplical complex everything is finite
it has a set of vertices v as usual and
and this is X is
just a collection of of subsets of
V which is closed
down that's it that that's the whole
definition so what do I
mean if
a so a is a subset of v and it's a
member in this collection so under this
these two assumptions that a is a member
in this collection and B is a subset of
a the conclusion is that b is a member
as well
okay and a little terminology don't
worry this is really very simple and and
if you never saw this this is it I mean
there is nothing complicated here a
members
of X are called I think this is perhaps
the other one is more
visible so no good members of X are
called faces or
simplies that's
the where the name comes from you'll see
in a second how uh and and if a
is a face then we
associate a dimension which is just the
cardinality minus one so think about it
for a moment it makes perfect sense a
point cardinality one has has Dimension
zero a pair has Dimension One it's an
and so on and so forth and the
dimension of X is the highest
dimension of a
face in X
okay so really make sure I
mean you know it's always discouraging
when you're in such a bunch of super
clever people to but but really now
don't you know don't be shy make sure
this is really crucial if you don't feel
comfortable with this definition then
you're in trouble for the rest of the
lecture so just make sure you're with me
it's really a very simple object but we
really need it so this is this is
crucial that you understand this so if
you think of a polytop each face should
be a Simplex then for example but that's
I but I want to to what is a one
dimensional simpal
complex very good but let's just make
sure that we are all on this point it's
a
graph that's the same as a graph why so
we have the usual terminology that we're
used to we have a set of fin a set of
vertices faces are zero or one
dimensional because the dimension is one
so and and so there are the vertices and
the onedimensional faces are just the
edges and what is this condition that if
you have a what is this condition if you
have an edge then of course the two
vertices are are there too okay so a g
is a onedimensional simpl complex okay
regarding your comment in the
dimensional case it's it's a case of a
it's a combinator version of a polytop
where every face is simp it's a simp
yeah simpl polop yeah but I don't even
want to assume that people know that and
I will not need it but let let me
explain why this so I don't want to go
into the history also I don't know it
well enough but this used to be a very
important object in in topology in the
early years and and then they somehow
took a different direction I don't want
to get into this but it's really for
combinatorial list it's really a very
very natural kind of of thing but just
why so why why what's the geometry why
why are were people or are people
interested in in this kind of thing in
in in Geometry because for example
that's a picture of a two dimensional
simpal complex so it
has this vertices it has the two
dimensional face 1 2 3 and of course by
the definition it it has also the the
the onedimensional face one two the Zero
Dimensional three this you have here
three onedimensional Faces 2 3 2 4 3 4
and this one okay so that that that
really explains why it's such a basic
geometric object because if you really
turn a
interpret simplies to be really
geometric simplies so so a triangle is a
two dimensional simp
tetrahedron is a freom and and and you
just create them and you glue them
together in the right way this gives you
a way to represent geometric objects
potentially quite complicated geometric
objects and uh so just as a comment why
did they fall out of favor the in the
eyes of the topologist because they have
more efficient ways of encoding
geometric objects CW complexes and so on
but the the great thing for us is that
this is completely combinatorial and and
we can think about it okay so that's a
that's a simplish and complex so the
big story of the big plan that I'm I'm
suggesting and certainly we didn't start
with us we'll come back to to older
things
is see I I it's really you know I've
been around long enough that in the you
know when I started to be a students
student I remember being
asked H by even teachers you know why
are you interested in combinatorics this
is you know what what's a clever guy
like you're doing in a place like this
kind of thing and of course now students
hear this and it sounds strange
but it really it's is a fairly
modern field and and by now I think we'
have gathered enough knowledge and
information and and and and depth that
it makes perfect sense to ask can we
somehow take what we have Acquired and
and and take it elsewhere so commics and
graph Theory you we have benefited from
other more classical areas of
mathematics for so many years we can
start paying back I mean many things
like this already happen and in
particular one thing which is I think
really a place where combinatorics can
really affect or what we've learned in
combinatorics can affect other areas of
of mathematics is the publicistic method
it's very easy to consider to look at at
random combinatorial objects it's much
harder to to look at com at random
objects in other areas and this suggests
a way of of doing this okay
so what this suggest is to develop so so
if I'm looking at gra Theory two of the
most highly developed part of of GRA
Theory so this which perhaps I will
mention one small thing at the end
extremal graph
Theory I mentioned it when I spoke about
locality and so it's it's a huge area
and deep and and Powerful so can we take
ideas from there and and study them here
and what I'll mostly be be talking about
today is is random graph
Theory and again with a great success
that we had with with this field I mean
this suggests can we
develop a good theory of random simpl
complexes what are the interesting
phenomena are they you know a prior it's
it's not clear you know perhaps uh
perhaps the the whole thing is just you
know you grind through the machine again
you get the same thing but as you'll see
no it's it's very very different and and
one thing that I hope the those of you
who were in the previous
lecture it's one thing that's really
very nice here is that when you go up in
dimension many things which are
completely obvious and boring and so on
you just tell them to under become
completely unclear and and and very
fascinating and so this is the main
thing that I want to talk about so in
the previous lecture
I mostly mentioned one collaborator my
my
studenta here there will be quite a few
more and I hope to do justice and and
mention each of them when the subject
comes so the this is this is what we're
going to do throughout most of of this
lecture speak about some first steps
that we're taken in this direction
developing a theory of of random simpli
complexes that's that's what we'll be
spending most of the time doing so uh on
on this I have I I have and I had many
great Partners but certainly the the
first steps were done with
roam so now let let me let me explain
a so I I don't want to even assume that
people here are I I want to assume that
everyone saw what G&P is but I I don't
to assume that people remember or know
precise I'll remind you what we need to
to know
about is online what can you
do this you didn't explain to me you
said B and everything becomes black I
mean it's only this
is through the back door
okay
cool okay
good
uh okay so let's start a little bit
about I mean it's mostly going to be on
the board but as you understand I have
two or three slides to show you at some
points is why I have it on okay so we
want to speak about
G&P this is of course the the
grandfather of of ROM graph Theory ER
mostly you know it was started by erish
and Reni in the late 50s early 60s and I
think it revolutionized the whole way we
we think about discrete objects so you
know but let me you have n vertices and
for each pair of vertices independently
and with probability P you you put an
edge and with probability one minus P
there is no Edge and and you can do
everything with any P but most of the
interesting stuff and what we will be
doing is is a p which depends on on M
and and if you want to summarize what
the most important Discovery you know
conceptually if you don't want to get
into the details what we've learned from
from the theory of of the G the theory
of G&P is the the phenomenon of
thresholds which is again a wonderful
subject worthy of of a lot of work but
uh lectures and so on I will not get
into this but the fact that
uh
phenomena of this sort tend to arise
very abruptly and at least I should
mention one one name here Hood
frood who did his thesis with Gil and he
did some marvelous things about specials
but just to okay so what what what did
erish and Reni do in the
fundamental
papers
okay
so
question is a
function of P How
likely is a
graph in G&P
to be
connected okay so for this I can show
you one
slide this is a student who did a
project with me did it on the computer
and here it
is
so so let's say this is
a n here is 100
and uh in fact uh this is not precisely
G&P uh it's a cousin of G&P and these
different models are are related to to
each other in very well understood ways
H so let me explain the exact experiment
this is what eres and Reni called the
evolution of random graphs instead of of
picking every Edge you sequentially you
start with end vertices and you
sequentially throw in edges at random
and this tells you so when you add a new
Edge one of two things can happen either
it will connect two distinct connected
components or it will fall in the same
way so he repeated this many times and
this is the probability that in Step x
uh you are connecting two different
components and you see the the behavior
of this okay and eventually it goes down
to zero when the graph becomes connected
then every Edge is going to so that
that's that's a very typical thing and
the fact that this has this
threshold General SC frame of
ofation is is a
general phenomenon so now we want to
understand the thresold for for
connectivity so
theorem ER RI 1960 or something
the critical P for for connectivity is
Lan of n over Okay so this has two
things I mean it can be stated in in
very very precise forms this is
understood to a fantastic detail but
just to tell you the most the the the
the most the strongest form let's say
a there are even stronger things than
this I will tell you in a minute if if
Omega of n tends to
Infinity with then then if I if P if my
P is done n minus Omega Over N then
almost surely G is
disconnected and if
p is l n plus Omega Over N then almost
surely it's
connected this is the the first part is
really easy
because from coupon collector you see
that if p is smaller than than l n Over
N then not only is the graph
disconnected it has isolated vertices so
that's very easy and what requires some
work but by now it's really fairly easy
is to show this okay so really
connectivity is perhaps the the the
simplest non-trivial graph property and
you could
ask is there an interesting High
dimensional analog of
so what what is the notion of
connectivity what what what do we do
with these things and as usual and in
fact as it was also with permutations
and so on this can be viewed in in the
real of graphs in many different ways
and and the whole thing is to find the
way
ER which gives you and there is so
that's already one one interesting uh
point to make which I alluded to before
with graphs it's completely clear what
it means for a graph to be connected
with a high dimension simp by the way I
will almost exclusively speak about
Dimension two because again almost all
the phenomena are going to be clear in
the questions and the difficulties are
going to be so just just that we have a
terminology between us that also
simplifies the language so we have
vertices edges edges means edges in a
graph and the the two dimensional faces
that I just call called faces okay so we
have three kinds of objects
okay how do you define have a give you a
collection of of triples and and pairs
every pair when do you refer to such a
thing as as being connected so first of
all one simplifying assumption that I'm
going to assume throughout which is
certainly not not crucial but this is a
choice that that mulam and I
did so h we're going to
assume so sometimes I will will speak
about D but most of the concrete things
I will do with d equal 2 we are assuming
a
full D minus
one dimensional
skeleton so I'm assuming that all the
faces of Dimension D below D strictly
below D are there and the only thing the
only random thing is which
D dimensional faces we're picking in the
case of graphs the vertices are all
there which edges are you picking a this
is by no means the only interesting
model that's the model we at the moment
understand the most about that that's
that's the only thing so when we want to
have an analog of GMP then what M and I
introduced is the model so we
pick the
faces independently
and with probability P so just make sure
that that you see that that for D equals
1 that's exactly
G&P okay so now we want to understand
what what connectivity means and there
is more more than one way of doing this
more than one interesting way of doing
this let me something that I'm not going
to get into at all so this is here I'm
winking to to the elephant you can ask
about simple connectivity for those who
who know what that is so the that's a
very
natural I'm not going to to go into this
but I have to mention it simple
connectivity
threshold studied and almost perfectly
determined in in work by
bobson of
man he
but I'm not even going to tell you what
that means I just have to mention that
there there's many more there's not one
definition there there a whole bunch in
fact infinitely many different
definitions and they're all interesting
and I'm going to speak about one which
is particularly interesting and and
amable to analysis and so
on so how are we going to
Define what connectivity means when we
talk about let's say two dimensional
simpl complex with a full one
dimensional skeleton so let's go back to
graphs we we're trying to
to get inspired by the situation of
graphs and and let's let's look at this
using linear
algebra so what does what does G&P look
like well there
is this inclusion
Matrix of the single tones ver versus
the pairs so what is this the columns
correspond to
all the pairs i j from one to n and this
column contains this is numbered I this
has two ones one in I and one in J and
and zeros
elsewhere
okay this is the
the uh this is the Matrix that
corresponds to to the the incidence
Matrix of the of the complete graph and
what do we do in G&P we
select
a
random
subset of the
columns
independently with probability
p and then we're looking at the Matrix
and we're trying to understand so how
how does the Matrix tell
us I I'm probably getting ahead of
myself here but so is there a reason
you're doing one one and not one minus
one doesn't matter so um okay
I'll I'll come back to the okay yeah
yeah it's a good question I I'll I'll
make a comment on this in a
minute
okay so
uh let's do it if you want like this
that's fine doesn't matter which but we
we'll see in a second but a how how do
we No in fact Let me let me stay with
the with the ones I I I'll comment on
this
momentarily but how how do we we see so
now I give you such a matrix let's say
this is how many columns this is the
incidence Matrix of a you're looking at
the incidence Matrix of a graph how can
you tell whether or not the the graph is
connected so this is the incidence
Matrix of a graph how do you tell using
linear algebra whether the graph is
connected or not so let's look this is
a how do you tell if G is connected or
Not by considering the left
kernel
of a of G so let's see well let's
understand this thing first of all so
now I'm doing everything and this is
coming to in a second to to your
question but I'm doing everything my
linear algebra of the field with two
elements okay so the left Cel of of of
AG certainly contains the all one
vector why if you gf2 any column every
column has has two RS over gf2 that's
that's zero but in fact if I did any
other field and I did plus and minus one
that would still that would still be the
case so and by the way that we already
see that there is a choice here many
more than one natural definition for
example we can do the whole thing over
different fields or if you know how to
do this then even over groups or Rings
or there is a whole variety and and
that's also part of the the story that
there is one more than than then one
definition that's all always there and
and G is
connected if and only if this is all
there
is is just this one
vector right because if it it's
disconnected you could help in the left
canel the indicator function of any
connected
component okay this is how l tells you
whether the graph is is connected or not
that's true right so if you put the one
in the minus one the right right right
right right right right the same thing
would would work over any field the the
convenience about F2 is that minus one
is is one and so I don't have things
become a bit simpler but uh what do I do
with all these
people now you'll soon find out who all
my friends
are okay
see why you are doing it
GF yes so why don't you get any
cancellation and get something else for
instance if you
have like a Cy where
everything like like you have let's say
connected component and go out of it
from the look let's we we're doing gf2
right so so the so vectors are just 0
one so a vector is just a set of
vertices and a column when do you get a
zero in a column if both vertices are in
the set or none of the vertices when
when do you get a a one if if there is
one vertex in the set and one outside of
it so connected set I mean if the G is
connected every set has edges going
outside right so this is okay so this
suggest a definition that works also
more generally so at least we are now
able to to
formulate a the
problem completely and and see what we
get so this Su just now the problem that
we want to solve so just to simplify
matters I will stay with F2 things are a
little simpler there but you can do the
same thing I I will make a comment about
what happens other thing so what's the
problem now we are start starting with
this
Matrix P versus
the and if I Ki if I get kicked from
home you'll you'll you'll tell them that
it was during a talk I couldn't take the
calls ah that you didn't
see what do I
do
oh am I going to get in trouble okay
it's my wife
calling okay
ER good so uh
you'll be my Witnesses H okay so we're
looking at pairs versus
triples against the inclusion Matrix so
this is the triple I JK there is one in
i j ik k JK one one one and the rest are
zeros we do the same thing we pick at
random every column independently and
with probability p and we ask so the
question
is what is so we consider this as the
trival left K we'll have to have a word
this will become a little more
complicated here but certainly not bad
what is the critical
P for the event there are no
non-trivial vectors
in the left
common so first we have to explain to
ourselves what what what what are the
trivial ones to R them
out let's say I do everything over the
field Ed two elements unless I'm saying
anything else for the moment everything
will be over the field Ed two elements
much of it goes through to other fields
but just to that that simplifies some
technicalities no no
we'll come back to other
fields but for the discussion everything
is the field with two elements so what
are what are the
trivial what are the trivial vectors in
the left
C you see if you saw any topology then
you must have
seen this thing whatever that means and
what what this means in our case is that
if I take it's a very easy thing to
check if I take these two
matrices and I multiply them one by the
other I get the zero
Matrix so in particular a all the row
space of
this n by n Cho 2 Matrix is contained in
the left
kernel this Matrix a so that's always
there a non-trivial means other than
that okay just think about it what was
this one this is the n choose Zero by n
choose one Matrix is just the all ones
Vector so this is really a special I
mean this is the same the same thing
again so this is what we're asking what
is the critical P for which these are
the only things in the left
C okay now let's see you remember that
in in in the other sh what was the what
was the the thing that that it was L the
critical P was l n Over N why because I
was was this is a guess at least that
would make sense that below this not
only is the graph disconnected it has
isolated vertices so what do isolated
vertices look like when we're looking at
it's such a matrix the vertices it's a
go that's completely zero
and then you get of course a non-trivial
vector in in in the left c l just take
this row take the indicator of of this
vertex so if here in the an 2 by 3 it so
happens that we get a row of zeros an
edge that is not covered by any face
then the answer is and if you do the
exact same coupon collector
argument
if p is less than 2 log
n minus Epsilon / n then I will say it's
disconnected in the sense that there is
a nontrivial left Vector in the left Cel
not only this even in the sense that
there exists zero
rows there exist an edge which is not
covered by any by any face we
haven't chose we didn't choose any we we
haven't selected any of the faces that
containing please so the two definitions
are not equivalent that any Edge so one
natural definition of not being
connected would be that there are edges
which are not covered by fa but that's
like an isolated vertex of course if
it's a if there is
an compare this with with being
connected ver is having no isolated
vertices so of course if you have
isolated vertices you're disconnected
but the two are not
equivalent the two are not equivalent
then the same same here okay so having a
a zero row is a sufficient condition to
being disconnected the vanishing of the
first homology in this case but they're
not equivalent so what mulam and I
proved is that the analogous
thing
holds
so in topologies in the language of
topologist this is how you write it is p
which is
two l n over the same the same thing so
of course the main part as it was with
with graphs the main part is to show the
the easy part I told you it's it's
really just a very simple thing the main
part is to show that if P exceeds this
so the main part is to show that if p is
2 l n plus little Omega Over N then
almost surely no such
vectors in left
C
Okay so just just just to get an idea of
of of a a way that would give me a
probably subal bound on P just want to
make sure I understand with the idea
idea of you I I would take I I I'm
trying to get a feel for what do
the what is the Rose space of this
Matrix even going to look like oh okay
the RO space of this is something that's
very easy you know what again you are a
step ahead of me I will return to this
in in just a second no no I will it's a
a very good question which I will return
to in a minute but let me just say one
thing because I promise to speak about
about other fields
so
M Mam's PhD student Natan valak did this
for
other
finite
groups of
coefficients say
thing in particular over any other
finite field and very recently just a
few days ago
a I'm sorry I should have learned the
name there are three authors perhaps
some people here
know so
Hoffman
kale and my apology for not
remembering the the name of the third
person person just a few days ago posted
on on
archive if you know what that that means
they showed that the threshold over the
integers is order of the in in general
these two in general Dimension is d
That's that we also know the same thing
a so they showed that the right order of
magnitude also with integer coefficients
but let's not even go into okay let me
try and give you
just a little f one so as I I promised
not to do any any hard proofs let me
just give you one item from from from my
work with mam on
how and just a little bit to think about
how uh how to go about proving such a
thing
okay so let's see a we we are trying to
understand we are trying to understand
the the left K
right refer to it a little inaccurately
as this is my complex just the the the
triples since I have a full
onedimensional
skeleton the only thing that matters is
which two dimensional faces I
have now we're trying to understand the
the the left C of this so we want to
understand if this is a we're interested
in non-trivial solutions for this right
and again just to simplify matters let's
say that that uh we're over the field
with
a you're so tired I'm really sorry for
you ER I'll try I'll do my best
ER so how do you think about it what is
such an X over the field with two
elements as you see this simplifies many
things so X is a 01 vector it's a z0 one
vectors
that the
indices correspond to edges two pairs so
such an X you might as well think of as
a graph right X is an indicator the way
we should want to think about it is X is
an indicator function of a graph okay
good what does this
mean so you take any
triple so corresponding to X is a graph
G and this means that for every chosen
triple so if f
is is a chosen
face F meets G
evenly this is a bad notation but you'll
understand is zero mode two in other
words it's either Zer or
two so what we really like to understand
is the situation so I think of X as as a
graph and and B of
G are so now I haven't I I don't look at
this is in general it's the
collection of
triples
faces that
meet G
oddly
okay
so essentially the
the the basic
equality that we want to prove I'm still
there is still something critical that I
haven't told you but we want an equality
that looks something like something sum
over G acceptable I explain this in a
minute
of 1us P to the B of G we want this to
be L low of one that's the meaning so if
P that's the key
LMA a key LMA a key LMA says that if p
is bigger than this 2 l n plus Omega
Over N then such a thing
occurs
okay that's the expected number of of
of columns here or faces that were
selected that would go against this
equality okay
so but what is
acceptable you see we understand there
is a part there is a Subspace of of the
left kernel which we really want to mod
out with by which we really don't care
about which means if you give me G and
you give me a
u in the so give me G and give me U in
in the trivial
kernel then whether G is in the left
kernel is equivalent to G+ u in the left
kernel in other words you can change
you're allowed when you're considering
when you're considering these candidates
to be in the left kernel you can modify
them by by sowing with any with any
trivial uh member in the so somehow what
I want is to select from any any such
choice so these
are just the coets of of of this
Subspace of the of the trival vectors I
want to select a canonical member from
every coret I want to select a canonical
member so now I have to answer your
question what what are the
trivial vectors in the kernel what do
they look like or in other words what is
the row space of this
so that's very easy to
tell each row
here what's the row space of
this a each row is just a star all the
edges that contain a that contain a
given vertex what happens if I add up
two such hes or any such set of holes
what I get again remember that graphs
here I think
of vectors here I think of of them as
graphs so it's exactly something like
this I partition the vertic set into two
parts it's a complete
bipartite graph on such a thing so these
are these are my my my trivial vectors
and so
now this allows me to to select what I
want is a
canonical choice
of a
member
in in coets in every
coet
of the row
space of this Matrix this is what I need
to
do H so the choice is really very
simple yeah if see you have a graph and
and this is one candidate that you can
sore with so which U will I choose I can
always make sure that in this particular
cut by cing if necessary with these guys
I I would like G to be a minority
here so if G is initially fewer than
half of these edges belong to G I'm
happy if there are the majority then
I'll s and compliment and and I'll get
so I can guarantee and that uniquely
determines the this canonical member
that g is
minority in
every
cut in one to
n that I can guarantee and and such a
g is consider
acceptable and then then you get this uh
then then this is dma that you prove I
will only tell you one more little thing
about a key step in
there so this is the kind of thing that
we want so what works for us is if this
number is
big we' like this
number to be big
and so Su of
this that we
prove and I just mentioned it my initial
plan was to prove it but I think this
would this stage be considered
inhumane the Suma says that if G is
acceptable then the number of triples
that intersect it oddly is at least the
number of vertices in G times the number
of edges divided by
three and this is
tight it's it's really not a difficult I
mean with a four here it's it's a few
lines proof but I will save it you why
let me only show you that this is
tight so you take this bip triarte graph
or whatever you want to call it the
vertices are partition to three equal
parts and the edges are just all the
edges that connect this and this so it's
very easy to see that this is acceptable
this this graph is a minority in every
cut that you take H so let's calculate
the number of vertices is of course n
the number of edges is n^2 over 9 right
everyone here times everyone here and
and what is B of
G let's think about it for a moment
which triples meet the EDG set of this
graph oddly so first of all this graph
contains no no triangles so meet it
exactly once so it's exactly you take
one vertex from
each and so that would be n /3
cubed so this is n / 3 squ and you see
that this is precisely so that's a
that's a key step in in the proof but
there is a much much more than that but
okay so the main thing is that we we got
the exact answer very
accurately
um
okay okay so is
itct yourself to
accept because we don't care the the
trivial the trivial vectors in the left
K we completely
ignore right this is the I mean if you
modify if you give me a vector and I
modify it by by trivial Vector in the
left col that doesn't change anything so
from this whole collection I it's enough
if I select one and I and I concentrate
on this and the one I select is this
particular one so the the
okay good so uh so this is more or less
H except
for that we'd like to really get this
thing uh completely nailed down
we'd like to eliminate this o this is
still o this part is more or less a
closed story but there is another uh
part of this Theory where really the the
Mysteries are still huge and it's really
wonderful and we're
still working on on on this H to that
very moment so let me try and and tell
you this uh so again coming back to to
eres
Reni the most exciting Discovery the
most exciting Discovery I think the mo
the most important discovery which they
didn't even spell out in this is this
generality is this threshold phenomenon
and the most exciting is the phase
transition at p 1/ n which I'm now going
to tell you please is there an
interesting problem here where the
coefficients are real no no no no it's
the same as yeah yeah okay good so uh
that's so the threshold does not
at all this is the conclusion it's not
it wasn't clear a prior but in hindsight
this is what turns out but
forer like iser no same thing same thing
what's the Matrix so first so what do
you put so because because you have to
change so once we work over a field
that's not characteristic too we had to
about one yeah yeah we need to we need
the so that requires orientation so you
Orient oh so you Orient uh you Orient
all the simplies and you put plus and
minus according to whether they're
consistent or not so that's one reason
why I evaded this here because that that
is a small headache that you have to go
through which you avoid if you go in the
field with two elements but if you want
to hear about this I'll be
glad the only thing I would just I I I
don't know just that's that's striking
me here is that you're basically what
the problem is now we we're pulling a we
pull a random subset of columns from a
matrix a that we're sampling uniformly
at random and we just want to say when
does the kernel coincide with the kernel
of the original Matrix so it's very much
like one of these Matrix concentration
equalities but I don't know if those
those don't work over gf2 of a finite F
no is there such a connection through
this I don't know but that's right okay
so so perhaps the most exciting
Discovery in in uh this uh early stages
of the theory of GMP was the phase
transition at P equals 1/ n and if you
never saw this I I highly recommend
it
okay so again it's easier to to look at
these things within the evolution of
random graphs so you you have nvertices
and you start throwing edges at random
and and ask yourself what is the
structure of of connected components
what do the connected components look
like so and and there is really a
fascinating thing which has been
investigated in great detail and in
great depth H which occurs at this point
so they really tons of of papers in this
and we Now understand this really really
well but for the purpose of of
relatively shallow
discussion if if p is 1us Epsilon Over N
for any Epsilon positive then G
consists of
small
simple connected
components so small
means all of them are at most of
logarithmic size and simple means they
are mostly
trees with the possible exception of a
constant number of a unicyclic so three
plus an
edge so very simple description what
happens around P equals 1 /
n and p is 1 plus Epsilon Over N then
very suddenly a giant component
emerges
so a giant means of cardinality Omega of
and that's a very interesting thing how
this thing happens and and
lots lots of of a interesting and and
surprising phenomena happen at this
point in
particular and this we would like to to
understand also in higher Dimension and
this at the moment we only have a
partial understanding of this and I'll
describe to you a little of what we
know so in
particular you
ask is a function of
P what
is probability
G that
we sample from GMP contains the
Cycles so if p is 1us Epsilon Over N
then there exists a c of Epsilon such
that this
probability this probability is less
than 1 minus C there is still a positive
chance that it's cycle threee but once
you have passed this point then
everything is then almost surely the the
graph already contains a cycle now the
advantage of of okay let me let me just
say
this one thing that's that's
obvious and we have only very initial
guesses about this I I'll show you
something that we see experimentally but
at the moment we we can't prove I should
start what is what is the giant
component in higher Dimensions so we
don't understand let me just say this
very clearly we don't understand but we
are starting
to to feel H this this animal what you
know what this is and and we have some
early hints but at the moment we we
certainly don't know how to answer this
so we try to go around this and and ask
questions that we are at least able to
formulate within our framework and then
this will allow us to at least get
started on on the
problem so where do you see again so we
now already saw that that linear algebra
is is a good guide in in formulating the
problems and looking at this so when
when I give you the incidence Matrix of
a graph where do you see the cycle so
the
Cycles this is a cycle
space is exactly the right
Cal of a right because if I multiply
here by a vector of of zeros and ones
this means I've selected a subset of the
edges and the the fact that it's zero
means that every vertex has an even
degree so the basic things are cyles
where vertices of degree Z or two so
this is something that we can ask so
this allows us at least to to formulate
this question also in higher Dimensions
so this
suggests the following
question again I will formulate it just
at D equals 2 what
is the critical
P by the way this uh this model that we
call it in general g x d n and p so d =
1 this is exactly G and P what is the
critical p in
XD and P
for their
being a a nonzero right
K so this in in the case of if D equals
1 we know the the Cal p is is is 1/ n
now let me take you a little bit to the
more uh conceptual side of of the story
and let's let's think a little bit more
about what this means
so in other words what we're asking here
being a cycle free means being being a
forest right so same
as
probability the G is a
forest and so the conceptual thing is
that the analog of this in higher
Dimension there are many more
options which are
interesting let's discuss them a little
bit okay so you all know the very simple
proposition the following simple
proposition from from graph Theory a let
G have n
vertices and N minus one
edges then the following are
equivalent one G is
connected two G is a
cyclic Three G is
collapsible so the first two of course
you know the third you know but I'm not
sure that you know that you know H so
what is collapsing collapsing is this
you take a vertex of degree
one and you eliminate both it and the
edge that touches it okay so collapsing
means that if you keep doing this you're
eventually remaining with
a with no with no edges you eliminate
all the edges this way so of course all
the three are are equiv
but now we know we have a language of of
formulating these these three properties
also in higher Dimensions so let's see
what they are so the analog of this
should be a no
non-trivial left
Kel this is no right
C
this is again collapsible so I have to
explain what collapsible
is I'll explain it just in two
dimmension so here what did we have we
had a Vertex a Zero Dimensional face
that was covered by exactly one
onedimensional face so in two Dimensions
if you have a onedimensional face an
edge that is covered by a unique face
then then we call this a edge
free and the collapse means that I throw
both of them
away okay now topologist will tell you
that
collapsing so collapsible means that
when I do this I eliminate all the faces
so topologist tell you that that the
topology of of a complex doesn't change
as a result of of
collapsing so you might think that that
same thing uh holds in general no so
it's it's very easy to show it's all
that
in in general one and two are equivalent
three implies one and two but it's not
equivalent okay and and so this now
suggests a two concrete questions to ask
one we already
solved one we have only a partial
solution
for so question
one what
is the
threshold for
collapsibility in XD
NP question
two what is the
threshold
for the
vanishing of the right
col okay so these are things that I
studied together with my student leor
Aron
Witham
and with thas
wuk so this question we we got
completely we know the answer to this
this question we got only
partly H so uh in particular it
so are the thrs different they're
different okay so here I'll tell what
H here is what I know as a person and
here is what I know as a
mathematician which are not the
same
so the answer for
one is p is let's say Alpha D Over N
Alpha D
is very close
to log of D and that is a full answer
for
two we know that P is less than or equal
beta d/ n where beta
D is 1us l l of one time D but we're
unable at the moment to even tell we
don't know how to get a lower Bound for
for two we can't even at the moment
prove that these two things are not
identical
and here we using all sorts of uh of
Machinery from from much more advanced
uh stuff from from a random graph
Theory
a just not to overdo it h let me spend
another few minutes on on the notion of
a tree and with that I will uh I will
finish so there is a very nice paper
from
1983 due to Gil where is it disappeared
yes please is there some any other
interpretation of
collapsibility that so it implies these
things but right is it equivalent to
something else we can think
about you see
okay they are quite this is a completely
combinatorial
condition and therefore we had much more
Machinery that we could
use and there we were finally so this
there was a paper of the four of us
where we got a lower bound on this and
then with ar we got a matching upper
bound and and we closed this thing here
I mean it's a little shameful and
luckily no one of you asked but I will
ask myself it doesn't the answer for
this depend on the field I probably
tired you already enough in the first
things people asked field field field
field and I said no no no not important
so people are now perhaps disguised
except for brave Mario Super
Mario no one would ask this but it's
shameful but I don't I'm not even sure I
know the answer to this so many things
here I know because no as a person as I
said because we experimented quite a bit
with h with these things but something
things I can prove and something we can
prove and we can't prove if I have to
guess then the the answer here also
doesn't depend on the field but I it's
still more but H actually
before
H before telling you about these
trees let me just show you one one
little thing from simulations which is
which is really
nice this is
why
before my other friends called me on
Skype and so on and my wife is looking
for
me
no is
it what would I do without the guy
okay ah okay so that you saw but in fact
Let Let me let me remind you because
this is a good reference to so again
what did we do here this is this is the
situation in graphs you have n vertices
you throw edges one by one and you ask
ah Gil you came back on time I'm about
to speak about
you you know
disappeared and you ask what is the
chance that I connect this Edge connects
two connected
components or or doesn't so this is the
okay so how how do you see in Lina
algebra about adding connecting in two
connected components this is does the
rank go up if you think about it for a
second you'll see it's independ so in
the first initially the rank each time
you add a column the rank goes up then
it starts going down and eventually now
let's do the same thing in two
Dimensions so again what do I have I
have a complete graph on N vertices and
I start throwing in faces triples and I
ask the same thing is the rank going up
you've added the column to The Matrix so
the the rank e can either stay or go one
up and see what happens I I find this
really
amazing this is the kind of picture I
can look at for
hours what what is this uh what is this
sharp threshold think of it it's pretty
amazing and and we still do not
understand what is going on but we have
some more than initial intuitions we
have some we are not completely in the
dark I mean if you came to me a half a
year ago I would say we are essentially
in the dark no now we together with with
another excellent student yal
ped we are now starting to understand
this but we're still far from having a
but let me explain why why this is so
amazing so what do we see here okay so
again let me see so n is 100 we have 100
vertices you have a complete and and
you're generating such a matrix a matrix
of 100 choose
two by so by some so initially it's it's
a as skinny as it gets no columns and
each time you pick a triple you pick and
and and you add it to the Matrix okay
now when you add initially of course the
the rank is zero each time you add the
column either the rank stays or goes up
by one and here so it's repeated I
forget 100 times perhaps what is the
chance that on step
5,322 the the the rank goes up so
initially the rank goes up each step and
then there is this sharp
drop so what happens here think about it
you have a matrix which so far you've
been able to add things to it and
they're linearly independ and then all
of a sudden so what I'm calling your
attention to is is this sharp threshold
as opposed to
relatively relaxed threshold that we saw
for graphs all of a sudden every new
column that you add every triple that
you add a creates a dependency so just
among you valent
myself we use this
metaphor it's a dream catcher that's
what we call it see you have these all
these triples no met a go home
they you have such a such it's it's such
an amazing object it's a simpl and
complex a two dimensional simplical
complex that capture everything that
that comes
through which previously just
beforehand nothing was captured we still
don't understand this this is this is as
far as I can
tell the best description that I have at
the moment I I I can tell more but but
all of this is is a conjectural we don't
have proofs at the moment or anything
that this is what happens so you see the
the the whole behavior of the appearance
of the first cycle in in one dimension
and two Dimension is completely
different in a graph we understand
exactly the length of the first emerging
cycle so again you start with n vertices
you throw edges and you look at the
first moment that the cycle was created
we know the distribution how long it is
and in in two
dimensions and that in fact we we proved
that we proved in in in work with this
Trio that either the first cycle that
you create is either the boundary of a
tetrahedron or it touches all the end
vertices it's quadratic in size sorry we
only know formally we only know
quadratic size experimentally touches
all the vertices so the two things
behave in a really radically different
way so there's really completely
different behaviors which at the moment
we we only are starting to understand
let me just briy and finally I think
you've suffered
enough that
picture it catches everything it catches
everything with probability 07 that's
right absolutely yeah you're absolutely
right you add the 4,000 you're
absolutely right and then we also don't
understand you're absolutely right
that's right the the the drop wasn't all
the way down as as Mario observed it was
to3 and it's easy to explain 18 but but
there are still 12 which I don't know
how to explain no the whole thing is
really the whole thing is really very
mysterious it's one of the situations
I'm a great fan of experimenting with
the computer but that's one case where
really the computer shows you things
that you know leave me
speechless but so the picture is the
same for a different
field this was done only gf2 I don't
know I so let me just very briefly tell
you a few last comments on on on trees
so of course trees are also very
fundamental combinatorial object here
the the basic definition is due his here
okay Gil from
83 and he looked into something like
this and and he asked so now you have a
full that's a
full D minus one
skeleton and you ask how many D faces
can you have here and still this is
going to be so so the rank of this
Matrix that that's say is nus one just D
minus one that's very easy to to prove n
minus one CH D sorry and and so the
right definition of of a tree or hyper
tree or QA cycli complex that that's
what what Gil introduced so a hyper tree
a de hyper
tree is a
set of n minus
one choose d d
faces such
that right Kel over the rationals is
zero that's his
definition and and these things are very
interesting you can investigate them let
me just give you a one they're very
different than than what we're used to
think about about trees you can also
take as a definition that it has this
many defas and it's collapsible that
would also be an analog there is really
a lot of of different possibility but
let me just tell you a small thing that
that youal P and I have discovered this
is proved already that's not just
experiments or
anything the So to that your picture yes
so it's why is it like kind of 3 4,000
so so you are saying the gra I mean the
hyper 100 points right so what you
expect well if it's 100
to no it's C Over N it's that c which I
mentioned before c over n * n 3 this is
where the drop
is the same C that I mentioned before
which is close to D Etc
okay so just to illustrate how different
these things are and and there still an
interesting uh choice to you know what
should we consider as the most
interesting or perhaps there are several
interesting definitions of an analog of
a tree so let's say you have in a graph
an almost
tree so this means n
vertices n minus 2
edges no
cycle now at
least half of the edges
are in the
shade
so what do I mean by this this such a
thing has two connected components such
an edge I call it in the shade if it
connects and and this is not in the
shade if you think about it how do you
minimize the number of edges in the
shade you make these two things equal
okay in in contrast so with theal pelled
there exists a two
dimensional almost
three with no
shade zero
shade so what does this mean it's a
simpl and complex a two dimensional
simpl complex it has n minus1 chose 2
minus one faces
and every face that you add to it you
get a a a q hyper
tree you Q hyper tree what what's what's
being in the shade means that when you
edit you don't get a
tree in there in in this example
everything that you add you get a tree
these things are completely different
very mysterious very
fascinating I think you suffered enough
it's time to stop thank
you
questions just a brief question that
um so in the previous talk the idea was
that to go into higher Dimension we took
things that we Associated as matrices
and then turned them into boxes hyper
cubes hyper arrays here while we move up
we we still putting everything back into
matrices right which is it's always one
dimension
down there's probably no connection but
I'm just kind of curious is the is there
is there is there a reason to avoid
something okay so
boxes I I I'll I'll answer a different
question if this is okay with you but I
think perhaps but perhaps the spirit
will so one thing that I was asked
especially people who like algebra ask
after I speak about these permutations
what I spoke in so there is one very
important aspect of permutations that
didn't exist here permutations of course
form a group there a symmetric group so
is there an algebraic structure as you
go
up for all I can tell the answer is
negative and in general I can say that
one of the nice things about
combinatorics is it seems like much more
robust part of mathematics than most
parts of mathematics it survives in the
desert on the mountains wherever you
throw it high dimension low Dimension
it's okay I'm is more gentle it needs
some some special conditions to to and
this is I think what what you're seeing
here so H it's very easy to develop the
the the combinatorics as as you go to
higher dimensions and all the supporting
terminology so the these are of course
these matrices of course we didn't make
them up they they come up if you think
about these things from the topological
perspective this is these These are D
minus first thology d thology all all
these things are are there from the
topological perspective in a very
natural way so here we don't create
anything new we just follow the the you
know the the existing the the questions
the these questions speak about the
vanishing of the D minus first mology
the first set and the vanishing of the
theology so in this respect we don't try
anything new we follow the the know
the and uh so I mean this talk you used
uh basically linear Concepts to define a
lot of these things but the previous
talk you said that defining High
expansion for higher simpal complexes
you said that the spectral thing doesn't
make sense not that it doesn't make
sense no no no no no many people are
that I know strong people are attempting
to to develop the the theory of of
expander graphs to higher Dimension
trying to use spectral ER techniques I'm
not a great believer in this I think
that that when you want to go with the
with with the expanders to higher
Dimension the right thing to do is to
understand random regular simplical
complexes and that that's a huge
Challenge and then that would set the
the standard so so we know in many
different uh ways that random regular
graph is is expanding just as well as
possible so if you understand how much
it expends then this sets for you the
standard for what you would be calling a
good expender for graphs and this I
think is the analog but at the moment we
have so many things missing I didn't
even get to speak about this the concept
of regularity in complexes is is
fascinating we know close to nothing
about this there is really still a lot
of theory to develop there having there
is chance for a lot of fun to be had in
in these in high
Dimensions I was wondering about the
algorithmic implications of going up in
dimension for instance in the first talk
you showed that for two dimensional
permutations you don't have beer cuffs
serum so you cannot optimize over
EAS so is this something general that
you see that when you go up in dimension
you see I mean any theoretical Compu
scientist would tell you you know that
going from two to three you know you go
from the settled land to the desert
right I mean 2 CNF is so easy 3 CNF
forget it and there but you know we
still not giving up right I mean people
are studying that it's really it's hard
but it's not
hopeless here I think while you know
this is honestly motivated at least to
to a large extent by by what I said at
the beginning that we will need this
kind of combinatorics if we want to deal
with situations where interaction not
per wise but but the the
algorithmic I'm afraid we will have to
wait a while until we understand
anything about this I i' be really glad
to see anything along these lines but as
you see the difficulties are still very
big
so so sometimes in math when especially
feels like topology where two and three
is hard and hopeless and 10 is out of
sight same time a million is is
fible is there any notion ASM totic
large really high dimensional phenomena
that still
survive it's it's not impossible there
are there are certain things for example
I not that perhaps Gil probably
understand these
things better than I do but for example
P's conjecture right I mean somehow five
dimensions and above so here I'm saying
words that I don't really understand but
I can at least say the right words five
dimensions and above there is one proof
that that relatively I think now for
topologist is considered not so
difficult and as you went down in
so special phenomena that occur in low
Dimensions is something that is
completely common place for for
topologists and I wouldn't be surprised
if we discover such things here as well
but we haven't so far so it's not
impossible that that when you really go
up in dimension a lot then perhaps
certain things become in some way
simpler it's not out of the question you
know there is a whole subfield of
topology a huge sub low dimensional
topology people work in low di it's a
all right thank you
n have a break and Rob will bring us
home